georges ginette l'estafette s'est arrêté
sur le marché coty à tour elle regorge
de fleurette sa propriétaire c'est julie
une jeune entrepreneuse qui a décidé de
faire de georges ginette un flower
trucks de compet voulais quelque chose
qui me ressemble à qui sont un peu récup
vintage
enfin je dis pas que vintage mais et
donc voilà je cherchais plutôt une
camionnette française soit citroën soit
renault et puis le hasard a fait que
suis tombé sur ginette cdu une variété
de saône du fenouil des chrysanthèmes
des oeillets houde et dania julie
propose plantes et fleurs de saison le
tout venant le plus possible de
producteurs locaux
par exemple on me demande souvent de la
rose là et à la rose en ce moment j'en
ai pas parce que c'est pas saison depuis
l'hérault ce que qu'on trouve ça va être
de la rose du kenya au d'équateur et ça
pour moi cette heure de questions
c'est comme la tomette on peut pas avoir
de la pivoine en décembre par exemple
en plus d'être sur les marchés
tourangeau la factrice de fleurs fait
dans l'événementiel elle propose des
cours de composition florale aux
amateurs et bien sûr le classique
bouquet de la mariée